foreign
ER stepping out with his wife Ariel the
day after he was ousted from the try
guys what it means to be a try guy in
new photos captured Wednesday Ned walks
ahead of Ariel looking unfazed by the
Scandal and in this snap her expression
says it all the sighting comes after Ned
begins his next chapter kicked off by
Tuesday's Bombshells we've come such a
long way up first longtime fans of the
try guys learned a shocking update on
social media quote Ned Fulmer is no
longer working with the try guys as a
result of a thorough internal review we
do not see a path forward together we
thank you for your support as we
navigate this change well we're finally
doing a video I never wanted to try
afternet wasn't featured in the group's
past three videos the announcement
confirmed what many already assumed
a short time later Ned revealed he was
part of a quote consensual workplace
relationship and offered an apology
quote I'm sorry for any pain that my
actions may have caused to the guys and
the fans but most of all to Ariel quote
families should have always been my
priority but I lost Focus yeah
cheers honey cheers Ariel Lynette
married in 2012. they share two kids
together in her words quote nothing is
more important to me and Ned than our
family and all we request right now is
that you respect our privacy for the
sake of our kids Ned's ousting came
during another high point for the try
guys I don't know that I fully realized
how much of a thing we are on top of
their 7 million YouTube subscribers the
group landed a series on the Food
Network
oh that was hot but amid the aftermath
Ned says quote the only thing that
matters right now is my marriage and my
children and that's where I'm going to
focus my attention
[Music]